hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be taking a look at tick
tock sensation and lifestyle youtuber
emily mariko but first let me tell you
about my sponsor ritual first of all i'm
not pregnant anymore and i'm finally
finished breastfeeding but i know how
many of you are trying to conceive are
already pregnant or recently postpartum
and you're looking to maintain your
health during this new phase of life i
know the supplement world is really
overwhelming but i like rituals prenatal
because first of all it's third party
tested and has 12 high quality nutrients
like methylated fourth generation folate
vegan b12 d3 and omega-3 ritual is all
about focusing their multivitamins on
the nutrients you actually need rather
than just throwing in everything but the
kitchen sink and they're really
transparent about where they source
their nutrients from and why as well as
their environmental impact so for
example they use a hundred percent
recycled material in their packaging and
their mailers are made from recycled
newsprint and plant fibers their multi
is also vegan gluten-free allergen free
with no colorants added sugar additives
or unlisted ingredients and these ones
have a delayed release capsule design
they also have a regular multivitamin
for men and women a 50-plus option a
post-single option and one specifically
for teens but it's super convenient
because they just deliver it to your
door as part of a subscription so even
when you're having super mom brain you
won't run out so if you want to try it
out you can use my promo code and check
out the link in my description to get 10
off of your first three months of ritual
all right back to the video now of
course before we get into it feel free
to pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also if
you're new here don't forget to
subscribe to this channel ring that
little bell and also if you haven't
followed me already on instagram and on
tick tock get on it at abby's kitchen
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
emily morico like where the f are you uh
in short she's solely responsible for
the viral salmon rice bowl that
everyone's making on tik tok you know
the one where she microwaves leftover
salmon and rice with an ice cube and
somehow the ice cube doesn't melt now
i'm going to explain said culinary
sorcery at the end of this video
so definitely stick around for that but
today we're going to be taking a look at
what the queen of meal prep tick tock
eats in a week so friends
get ready to be
inspired let's start with breakfast
[Music]
that is my style okay fun fact all my
boys husband included love something
that my son e has coined candy avocado
where we basically just pour balsamic
glaze on an avocado and then eat it with
a spoon it does in fact taste like candy
it's so good as we can see from this
example emily's go-to breakfast is
usually some kind of avocado toast so
she's either keeping it simple with like
a little salt and chili flakes on top or
she will top it with a sunny side up egg
dress with some arugula and balsamic
glaze as we just saw in either case i
love that we're getting some healthy
fats from the avocado
avocados
we got carbs from the toast and fruit on
the side and obviously i'm partial to
the addition of the egg which will also
add in some satiating protein but if
she's not feeling the egg she could get
her protein fix here with like a little
side of greek yogurt or maybe like a
protein shake on the side other days she
does pesto eggs or like a cheese ham and
egg combo so clearly she's a savory
breakfast gal and she does love her eggs
which is great because they're a
nutrient-rich source of protein and
vitamins a d e folate iron and zinc now
full disclosure this video was not
sponsored by the egg farmers but i do do
some ambassador work with them so i am
well versed on the research on eggs but
i often do get asked if it's okay to eat
eggs this often in a week in short we
used to think that foods rich in dietary
cholesterol like eggs significantly
raised blood cholesterol but we now know
that that's not really a huge concern
because blood cholesterol levels are so
tightly regulated in the body one very
large international meta-analysis with
almost 200 000 people found no
association between egg intake and blood
lipids mortality or major cardiovascular
events and one study specifically on
folks with pre-diabetes and type 2
diabetes found that eating 12 eggs per
week was not even associated with an
increased risk of heart disease so the
american heart association currently
recommends an egg a day for most people
or two eggs a day for folks who have
other dietary limitations like older
individuals or vegetarians in other
words if you love your eggs which it
sounds like emily does you can
definitely include them regularly any
way you like okay let's take a look at
her lunches
[Music]
okay so here we have a nod to emily's
japanese roots with this kiyashichuka
dish right here which is basically like
a cold ramen noodle dish with a variety
of colorful toppings so emily tops hers
with some egg and ham for some protein
fat we got cucumber in there for some
veggies and of course we've got the
ramen for our carbs now this is a
slightly lower fiber higher sodium dish
with the soy sauce and the processed ham
but i acknowledge that these ingredients
are characteristic and traditional to
the dish so i don't necessarily want to
take that away so rather than removing
we can add in some extra leftover
potassium rich veggies like any kind of
leafy greens or mushrooms some zucchini
or broccoli because basically sodium and
potassium have an inverse relationship
in the body meaning that when we consume
more potassium it helps to kind of
balance out any excess sodium levels in
the body now another way we could keep
the sodium levels low in this dish would
be by opting for a lower sodium
alternative to soy sauce like coconut
aminos it actually has a very similar
flavor to soy but has even less sodium
than a low sodium soy sauce and then we
could also do like shrimp in place of
the ham some days which is also a very
traditional protein topping for this
dish as for the rest of emily's lunches
she'll either have like a light salad
with some veggies and mozzarella we got
leftovers from the previous day's dinner
we've got a sushi takeout from the
japanese market or she will like go all
out and prepare kale chips from scratch
and a bean dip from scratch with like
all the fixings and that looks delicious
as well so we've got lots of great
variety in her week and you guys know
that i love to see variety because it
really encourages us to get in a nice
range of micro and macronutrients over
time even more importantly though is
that she seems to be really enjoying
cooking and she loves to experiment with
new recipes and ultimately that just
makes eating a nutrient-rich diet a lot
more realistic and sustainable but let's
take a look at emily's snacks
[Music]
okay so emily's go-to snacks are usually
some kind of fruit in this case we've
got nectarines peaches and a plut which
some of my favorites and then she's got
a side of a carrot with some [ __ ] and
sauce [ __ ] which is basically like a
vegan nut dip made out of almonds so
we're getting a good hit of fiber from
the fruit and veg plus some healthy fats
and a little bit of protein in the dip
that right there looks like a great
hunger crushing combo to me but for days
that she maybe would need something a
little more substantial to carry her to
her next meal she could try to up the
protein here by maybe throwing in some
cottage cheese with a fruit or she could
make her own bitchin sauce with greek
yogurt for example as the base i mean if
anyone can make a bad ass high protein
bitchin sauce dip it's emily morico so
i'm throwing her that challenge
selfishly so that i can make the recipe
myself emily girl don't let me down all
right finally let's take a look at
emily's dinner meals for the week
because i need some inspo
[Music]
i am such a sucker for a simple sheep
and dinner and this combo screams
balanced easy weeknight meal
so we're getting some protein and
healthy fats from the salmon we got
veggies from the broccoli and carbs from
the potatoes with a little bit of extra
fat and flavor from the parmesan cheese
for good measure easy flavorful balanced
and nutrient dense which seems to really
be the running theme with the majority
of emily's meals other than the sheet
pan meal we've got some zoodles with
pesto and sausage one night we got like
beef teriyaki with rice and cucumber
salad we got the hodgepodge of leftovers
as she calls them or we got a burger and
fries from a restaurant so again i
wanted to say that i really appreciate
the variety here but also the reality
that even a food vlogger doesn't want to
cook every meal from scratch every
single day people ask me all the time in
my weekly amas if i cook dinner every
single night and every time i give them
a big fat hell no leftovers are great
but honestly it's also
totally okay to order in or take out or
go out for a meal as well when your week
looks as colorful and nutrient dense as
this so i'm seeing such a beautiful
variety in emily's meals with like tons
of healthy fats and different proteins
and colorful produce that there's
absolutely room for a burger and fries
and really whatever other convenience
staples would make getting a balanced
meal on the table realistic and
sustainable for her let's be real we are
coming up to new year's year which is
generally when a lot of people make
these hardcore resolutions to like meal
prep and cook everything element from
scratch every single day of the week but
guess what that typically results in us
burning out and we are back to eating
cereal for dinner every single night by
valentine's day
it's a thing i love that this video is
packed with amazing meal inspo but if
cooking isn't your jam i don't want
anyone walking away from this thinking
that this level of domestic goddessery
is necessary for good health it's more
than okay to pick up a rotisserie
chicken and like a bag a pre-washed
salad for dinner or to have oatmeal from
a packet five days of the week making
small manageable changes are way more
powerful than going balls to the walls
on the meal prep and then burning out
with all that said what are my thoughts
on emily's diet well based on our
calculations emily's eating roughly 1500
to 1600 calories a day which is probably
on the lower end of where i would expect
her needs to be but of course these are
all just estimations now if that were
the case i would probably try to add in
maybe another extra snack in the mix so
possibly something with a little extra
protein since her fruit snack is a
little bit more carb heavy and that way
we'd have a really nice spread of macros
throughout the day having said that i
really don't get the impression that
emily's like intentionally restricting
any calories foods or food groups i've
seen her eat bread here i've seen her
add oil to the pan and
i've seen her eat white ramen noodles
without any kind of moral disclaimers
about it being a cheat or bad or
whatever nor did i hear any of her meals
come accompanied by any kind of
pseudoscience claim honestly it feels
like it's been a pretty good day over
here for me what i'm ultimately saying
is that if these portions feel good and
satisfying to emily then that works for
me too now i also think that it's quite
apparent that emily has a passion for
home cooking and meal prep which is
associated with increased food variety
and diet quality now the only thing
related to diet quality from this week
of meals that i would flag is that her
calcium and iron did look a little bit
low and it's not that she's not eating
high iron or calcium rich foods in her
diet i mean we saw some great options in
there like spinach beans red meat
broccoli and fish for iron and things
like cheese and dark leafy greens for
calcium throughout the week but she may
just want to kind of rejig her portions
to prioritize these types of food more
often we could also add like a source of
iron to her fruit snack with maybe some
nut seeds dark chocolate or dried
apricots since pairing iron-rich foods
with vitamin c from fruit will also help
to enhance the iron absorption as well
and we could add in like some yogurt
milk or fortified milk at breakfast or
snack and some edamame tahini or calcium
set tofu for lunch and dinner for our
calcium pro tip here folks look for the
words calcium chloride or calcium
sulfate on the ingredient list of your
tofu to ensure that you're getting the
higher calcium choice all that said i
really get the sense just from watching
this video and also her tick tock that
emily's food choices are really going to
vary day to day week by week depending
on what she feels like and maybe what
ingredients she has on hand so my bet is
that over the course of like a few days
or weeks emily is roughly hitting all of
her needs so my comments here are
largely just for inspiration and
education not out of actual legitimate
concern and that's because she's not
intentionally limiting or restricting
any particular foods the best diet is
always a very diet not one that's
meticulously planned out and repeated
day-to-day and i really think that
emily's doing an amazing job inspiring
all of us to get creative ourselves as
well as for the ice cube hack i did
promise you your little chemistry class
for the day yes science
okay so the water molecules within a
cube of ice basically get stuck in their
place because the hydrogen bonds prevent
the water molecules from rotating the
result is that the ice cannot convert
the microwave's radiation into heat and
the ice stays intact this is why the
defrost setting on microwaves exists
because it basically only heats the food
for a few seconds every minute because
it's essentially waiting for the hot bit
in like your chicken breast to melt
their neighboring areas now with rice
specifically adding that ice cube and
then covering it with some parchment or
wax paper helps to create steam to leave
you with luffy delicious rice don't you
guys
love science science rules and on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below to let me know who you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]